あっはい
こんなを始めた像ですはじめハウス
内見運転です
はいという皆さん前回はですね外観双剣の
家の外観を見たと思うんですけども芯に
うるさいなぁって僕を内見したときに何か
見たんですけどももう
意味わかんないレベルで何かすごいことに
なっていますこれ本当にひとりすぐかなっ
てくれるかの広いですしでも凝っちゃっ
たらにはただけこんな家の中見ることない
と思うので是非私と一緒にルーツはして
いきましょうどうぞ
では行きましょう
見ても銀貨の扉の大きさ等も私より大きい
はぁ
うわぁ
[音楽]
ブーバー
しん
ばいばーいああいいとかアンダー演奏って
いう感じの玄関でございますで一回見て
いきましょうえっ
廊下の好みて凍っ
東ボーリングできそういやほんと分くらい
うーん
ここですよねん
低レベル人民はからものゼロスやのこの
建物が何回かわかると思うんですけど入れ
ネーダーがないといけないぐらいの会場
ですものが僕大変なんだねやっぱりふーっ
ゲーマー
家にエレベーターのかあっはぁ
あれ
me
さっきましょうかも全部ね開けるという
ものが入ったりもう一人あぐらやっぱです
よこことかこれ本当だすごい
黒刀つの部屋では1階のメインルームて
いきましょうここがして来いよねもう
[音楽]
平和
かっこいい
すごい
篤人みたいな感じですねあそこがすごいん
ですよ見て下さいこのかなーれない子の方
がいいるぜそうだから
グルトっ
[拍手]
どっちにお店ができるか実行すると
甲府にお店がないけどこういう感じでもう
めちゃくちゃもノー収納ができます
ユーチューバー結構のの使うことが多いん
ですよ奨励どうもこことかで全部一気に
ことですけどいろんな武器みたいという
ことはここか分いろいろ考えてこういうの
がいいかなと思っに
行きましょうではついてにょと思います
リーダーを見てほしいますもう
階段の折り返しあったばいばーい粉
will return 様いらんって
言ったらいいとは考えているここだけ渡し
たことはうん
このいくだけなのでそのスペース号
やはりのでさあ猫がサーバ向けられました
行
あっそしてこちらなん
[音楽]
庭が見渡せます
なぜタバコ吸ったん
吸いたくなっちゃう水だけ好まず空いた
からじゃよきここですじゃあも見えた見え
たここにタバコとかいいから加工なってる
の試しなので空をもうれが席にも頼む的な
しているけどね個人的には理解のここが
一番かっこよかったの
いきましょうはい
[音楽]
おいなんだよ頃母
ブーブーってこれいやいやバイっ
ねぇ
パティロってへぺんっ
はっぽい所せていただいて行って見て来
にょ
溶剤
これねー
よくないわだって bon な見たこと
ないもうこんな照明
par
またはそうやって使うんじゃなぜてん
ちょっとキッチンがすごいだし見て再これ
わけのわからん技に言うとこのキッチン
だけで家一軒指すらしいですえっ結婚前
マンするぐらいの特殊なキッチンだし冷蔵
庫はもこれとこれ冷蔵庫なんですよ
馬でこっちがん
ビアガーデンですねやーそうですねはい
入っても
二つ一つ引っ張ってるんです
わっはっは
思います
確かにぞここね海近いから開封とかが来
たりした時はこれ締めてはい性を強くする
らしいこんなに子と一緒に遊びます
kenken いやさあここからが関係で
ございます3階もからと雰囲気が変わり
ますどうぞ
yeah動いよねこれ
まずくっ雰囲気変わるはちょっと高級な
日本食の居酒屋語ったトイレまでの空の見
ちゃっ
を生き抜けなんでこれすげー
凸で火炎瓶降ってくるドッキリできますね
できますね前住んでたオーナーさんがその
お母さん一緒に住んでてここで言うと
みんなの団欒しているところみたいなって
いう作られた場所らしい a
こっちにもう一あるっ
サービス
にょ
変十分すぎん俺すごいて何部屋ナースか
ここはこれは内目じゃないと言う多分ゲス
くるーなるかだそういうきま
ユーチューバーさん来たら混んでる要求
するまあ
[音楽]
ブービー12行き説明しけど活気一丁デー
とかあるんだよっ
ブーバーしをこすって寂しくなりの街で
上げたらこれでしょ a
いってもにわかってそして皆さん
なんと4回があります見て4回だけ
ちょっと雰囲気違いません扉の俺の
イメージだとここは海デートルームいない
動画と役だとした肇社長の子って書くん
じゃ見る異名ちょっと言えばいいといえば
すぎます
[音楽]
した
要望
どうぞ
ロック語ってる部屋ちっ
定価すごいってここ本年ポリよね逆や4回
も本当に年か誰かが住んでたなという感じ
がしますねちっ
もう誰か乗っていないすごいよね収納
すごいってこっちもの収納や油分
管理仕切りいうと分ネジもえっに
すごいすごいすごいすごい
ここにお部屋がですねですもうちょっと
また改造して何か良い家にあってきたかと
思う
てここなかなかお部屋ですもう
わからんだろうそしてここが一番の見所か
も知れませんぞ
なんだ
[音楽]
ええ
ええいろいろへ今後に starting
line ペットロスならない女をこうし
て by 旅行して後年間他にやが
ちらほらとあるんですけどもそして子が大
産牛です
[音楽]
ヤバイって結構霊子がとってたんでこの海
肇社長のずっと怒りのある海の近くに大津
を買ったという感動的なお話は6風俗は
入ったいわけで新居でございましたず色々
ととの a からこれもまたここにすぐ
スマいいしフラ明治もすぐ来るとかそう
いう話動画たぜてないんで開発たって話
でしたかとというところです
神路しようぜい
[音楽]
うぉっ
は